[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro 10 et 8 débat impossible de les
rater dans la librairie les cahiers de
vacances ont fait leur apparition il ya
quelques semaines destinés à maintenir
au conforter les apprentissages de
l'élève et connaissent un grand succès
tout en étant controversé alors doit-on
obliger les enfants à faire des devoirs
pendant les vacances d'été ou bien
faut-il laisser se reposer et s'amuser
c'est le thème du débat du jour avec moi
en plateau julie est denise and bonsoir
bonsoir concept professeurs des écoles
en élémentaire à poissy vous êtes
également élu au sein d'une gaine cfdt
soit 118 c'est le syndicat général de
l'éducation nationale à vos côtés
michael tan bonsoir en seront à vous
êtes président de la fcpe 78 la fcpe
c'est la fédération des conseils de
parents d'élèves
en face de vous manuela alfonso cancel
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes président de
l'apec à montigny le bretonneux la feps
la fédération des parents d'élèves de
l'enseignement public merci à tous les
trois d'avoir accepté l invitation alors
les vacances estivales vont débuter dans
quelques jours depuis plusieurs années
ces vacances arrivent mais bien souvent
avec cahier de vacances
un rapide tour de table que pensez vous
de ces cahiers je commence par vous moi
je suis pas contre je mais je n'oblige
rien il n'y a eu aucune implication à
mon sens ça rassurera les enfants ça
rassure les parents et puis enfin moi je
le prends plus comme un moment de
partage avec les enfants et un moment de
plaisir à partager entre les parents et
les enfants
on parlera bien sûr en détail à tout à
l'heure michael haneke que pensez vous
de ces cahiers de vacances entend par an
alors en tant que parent en fait il faut
voir à quoi ça se rapporte je pense que
c'est une envie de réussite
de la part des familles tant qu'elles
soient à ce que les enfants réussissent
et donc il faut se poser la question de
savoir si ces cahiers sont adaptés à vos
fêtes de de permettre cette réussite est
donc il ya un certain nombre d'éléments
qui montrent que c'est très dépendant de
la façon dont l'ugtt dont ni les
utilisent et puis et puis il faut voir
aussi que ce temps là sur les cahiers se
fait sur sur un temps de vacances
donc voilà je voulais c'est peut-être
par les menus la fonction de votre point
de vue sur ses cahiers de vacances alors
en tant que maman pour moi ces cahiers
c'est quelque chose d'intéressant pour
pouvoir partager un temps avec son
enfant le stimuler mais il faut toujours
que ça reste à la demande de l'enfant ou
alors que ce soit fait de manière
intelligente c'est à dire vraiment pour
le remettre dans une dynamique
d'apprentissage en vue de la rentrée
scolaire
mais un enfant a quand même besoin de
profiter de ses vacances alors océane
d'asie allaient audrey chaillou sont
allés justement demandé aux saint
quentinois ce qu'ils pensent et des
devoirs de vacances on regarde il faut
que les enfants gardent le rythme et
qu'elle continue à travailler
voilà après c'est bien d'avoir du choix
à individualiser par rapport à certaines
difficultés d'un enfant pas voir
peut-être un choix et dans les communes
d'action de l'école nous avons besoin
il faut qu'ils sont un petit peu
volontaire pour pas que ce soit la croix
et la bannière pour le faire travailler
mais effectivement si ils ont besoin
pour inciter un petit peu puis voir si
ça accroche
il faut pas non plus que ce soit le
rythme scolaire de l'année de toute
l'année mais il faut l'aider il faut lui
maintenir en forme comme moi je suis de
la vieille école je suis plutôt pour les
cahiers de vacances mais je ne veux pas
non plus se soit imposé on peut le faire
qu'une heure par jour où ou à des
moments creux codes de la journée on
n'est pas trop occupés mais faut pas que
ça devienne non plus une corvée
une réaction ça vous a fait sourire
julie denizen ouais moi ça me fait
sourire parce que j'ai fait ma réunion
parents d'élèves ya pas longtemps pour
remettre les livrer c'était vendredi
dernier
et justement c'est ce que j'ai conseillé
en fait à tous mes parents d'élèves
c'est à dire que en plus moi je fais
partie d'un je suis enseignant sur ainsi
un des doublés donc j'ai vu la nouvelle
la nouvelle mise en place pour pour
aider les enfants à prendre mieux entre
les cas la lecture et les mathématiques
et moi je trouve que c'est important et
c'est ce que je conseille qui est une
demi-heure le matin une demi heure
l'après midi parce qu'on sait que les
temps d'apprentissage sont différentes
chez les enfants et que souvent ils
apprennent mieux quand même le matin et
il ya un pic que qui revient en fin
d'après midi et je suis à relativement
d'accord c'est à dire que si vous vous
demandez à un enfant même un adulte
d'arrêter toute activité qu'il est
habitué à faire pendant plus d'un mois
là c'est très difficile de se remettre
dedans et je pense qu'un enfant surtout
en élémentaire il est rythmé par des
rituels nous en classe c'est très
ritualisé on fait régulièrement les
mêmes choses au même heure et si vous
coupez ces rituels là vous n'aidez pas
l'élève dans l'apprentissage
donc je pense que c'est important
effectivement que qu'ils puissent garder
ça surtout de la lecture
la lecture est un travail d'écriture
parce que parce que parce que c'est
s'est s'incliné stasi clé vous perdez
très très vite l'habitude d'écrire les
mouvements d'écriture quand vous êtes
enfant il faut parler justement la durée
des vacances seul durant un peu moins de
deux mois justement ce que finalement
ces vacances je m'adresse aux parents
est ce que ces vacances ne sont pas trop
longue trop longue
non parce que les enfants comprennent
quand même
beaucoup de moi à d'apprentissage
auparavant après lé deviennent longue
dans le sens où l'enfant finit par
s'ennuyer après avoir fait le tour de
ses activités prévues et c'est là
justement que prend le sens du cahier de
devoirs et de ce que je vous disais tout
à l'heure la remise en condition
intelligente c'est à dire que là pour le
coup l'enfant va être va réclamer à être
occupé à être stimulés et là il va être
dans de bonnes conditions pour
retravailler
par contre sur un peu gêné avec le terme
devoirs de vacances ce terme me dérange
pas même le terme de voir oui le terme
devoir me dérange déjà c'est une
antinomie on peut pas être en vacances
et avoir des devoirs enfin tu sais pas
logique
et puis pourquoi est ce qu'il faudrait
devoir faire quelque chose pendant qu'on
est sur un temps de repos
mikaël tam et vous partagez cet avis
alors donc sur la question du temps
le calendrier est là nous on considère
que effectivement peut-être ce serait
mieux de revoir les calendriers que ce
soit sur la journée sur la semaine et
sur l'année et donc probablement
faire en sorte que ces vacances soit
plus courte mais mieux et se passer le
temps puisque effectivement le temps des
élèves français est très concentré et en
son temps dans d'autres pays c'est ça
l'est beaucoup moins
voilà donc il ya cette question là sur
la question de de la répartition écoles
et hors de l'école on est les parents
sont membres de la communauté éducative
donc ce sont des co éducateurs et donc
on fait chacun une partie du travail du
travail ou deux on a chacun un rôle dans
l'éducation de l'enfant
il est donc à partir de ce moment là le
parent a des compétences différentes et
un rapport différent avec l'enfant par
rapport à vos enseignants et donc on
peut amener un tas d'autres choses et
donc je pense qu'il faut jouer sur cette
complémentarité est pas considéré que le
temps de vacances c'est juste un temps
on doit réviser ce qu'on a appris en
classe
l'éducation c'est bien plus large que et
la réussite est bien plus large de la
réussite scolaire et l'éducation est
aussi bien que larges que le temps de
l'école et de la scolarité
un enfant qui a beaucoup de lacunes on
va dire durant l'année scolaire
je lui faisais ce qu'il faut quand même
pendant ses vacances peut-être pas le
mois de juillet mais peut-être mois
d'août il faut quand même pour ces
élèves là par exemple qui ont un peu
plus de lacunes que les autres il faut
quand même en fait un temps de révision
comme vous venez de le dire
chaque personne chaque personne a son
rôle à jouer et
et deux mois de vacances pour un enfant
qui a des lacunes s'il a pas un papa et
une maman qui sont capables de l'aider
ça servira pas à grand chose j'ai envie
de vous dire parce que moi je suis quand
même dans un secteur où j'ai beaucoup de
parents d'élèves qui qui ne peuvent pas
du tout aidé leurs enfants dans le
domaine scolaire
maintenant moi je pense que les cahiers
de vacances ils sont justement là
beaucoup surtout pour les enfants qui
aiment l'école qui comme je dirais que
les enfants la finale sont plus
demandeurs vraiment faim droit pour
acheter des cahiers de vacances ils ont
faim c'est ce que c'est comme ça que je
le dis avec mes mots à moi parce qu'ils
adorent ça en fait il adore apprendre il
adore se lire un documentaire il adore
faire des exercices ils adorent venir
vous montrer le résultat ils sont fiers
de ce qu'ils ont fait les enfants qui
sont en difficulté ils sont en
difficulté pour beaucoup de choses et
notamment par rapport à ce que je vous
disais des fois juste rentré dans
l'écriture c'est juste une horreur pour
ces enfants la rentrée dans la lecture
c'est très difficile et très compliqué
quand on est en échec il ya des raisons
et c'est ces raisons là qu'il faut aller
travailler donner le goût de la lecture
donné le goût de l'instruction aller
faire des musées des visites des sorties
moi j'allais ya d'autres moyens
finalement les vacances pour simuler
justement
les connaissances plutôt qu'un tel moi
j'ai essayé de stimuler mes élèves en
leur donnant tout le travail de l'année
et en leur demandant de faire ce qu'on a
fait tout au long de l'année scolaire de
jouer à la maîtresse avec leurs poupées
de reprendre le travail qu'ils avaient
fait toute l'année c'est jeu comme c'est
ce qu'on a fait en classe ils ont mis
sur youtube on s'auto corriger
ils vont repasser derrière ce qu'on a
déjà fait ensemble avec un autre crayon
et ils ont droit de mettre leurs
annotations puisque ce sont leurs leur
fille selon il ya d'autres aussi moyens
justement de ces cas il balance pour
stimuler donc parler de musées notamment
par exemple il n'ya pas que ça il va y
avoir dans mille enfants emmenés enfants
voire un musée c'est bien mais ça reste
ça reste de la stimulation de passive
là où ça peut être intéressant ça peut
être de lire une recette de cuisine de
calculer des quantités pourquoi pas
essayer de mémoriser des parties de
france sur une carte routière
il peut y avoir tellement de petites
actions qui peuvent être fait pour
stimuler et l'intelligence la réflexion
et la créativité de l'enfant qu'il ne
sera que bénéfique pour l'heure pour la
rentrée scolaire
après je ne suis pas professeur je parle
j'ai pas d'expérience d' expertise
particulière dans ce domaine là mais en
tant que parent c'est là que le sens et
du que le rôle d'éducateurs prend tout
son sens c'est de continuer à dans une
démarche vraiment de continuité avec
l'année scolaire à stimuler l'enfant
mais sans que ce soit une charge
intellectuelle pour lui sans qu'il ait
l'impression d'être derrière son bureau
avec son cahier son crayon est vraiment
partir dans d'autres formes d'un
téléthon intellect or il existe aussi
des cours de soutien tout au long de
l'année
il y a aussi des cours de soutien
spécifiquement pendant pendant justement
les vacances les vacances d'été où vous
en pensez quoi
ces cours de soutien est ce qu'il faut
alors la question qu'on peut se poser
c'est si l'enfant des difficultés il
faut se poser la question de savoir
pourquoi il les a
effectivement il peut avoir des besoins
particuliers les est un handicap ou même
à une précocité
c'est on s'aperçoit nous beaucoup dans
les commissions d'appels donc des
enfants qui se retrouvent à vouloir soit
sauter une classe soit redoublé ou un
sont pas d'accord sur avec l'école sûr
parce que l'école prévoit pour eux que
en fait ces enfants n'ont pas été
accompagné comme il le fallait par
exemple pour pour un handicap
les un certain nombre de choses n'ont
pas été mises en place dire des mots
barbares parfois il n'y a pas de le pap
n'est pas appliquée le ppr eux il ya un
certain nombre de faits précis vie alors
c'est le plan particulier de réussite
éducative si du petit donc en gros il
faut se poser la question de savoir
comment accompagner l'enfant et l'autre
plutôt que ce serait un peu comme un
médecin qui déciderait de donner du
sirop juste parce que quelqu'un tousse
je pense que c'est important d'analyser
et pour ça que vous avez des personnes
qui peuvent vous aider dans l'école
notamment l'enseignante mais pas
uniquement parce qu'elle a un regard
il ya aussi notamment les psychologues
scolaires les médecins scolaires
et puis aussi les autres parents qui ont
un peu d'expérience et qui peuvent vous
aider à prendre du recul par rapport aux
difficultés de vos enfants parce que
souvent salée ça ça stresse beaucoup les
familles et il arrive parfois aussi que
les deux parents est pas le même selon
leur vécu avec l'école est pas le même
ressentie par bon à cette difficulté est
donc voilà je pense qu'il faut être un
peu plus large que juste être dans une m
un sparadrap dessus parce que la
personne qui fait qu'il va faire ses
cours supplémentaires comme ça eh bien
il n'y a aucune liaison avec avec
l'école d'origine et donc à mon avis
l'efficacité est moindre que si vous
investissez dans le fait de bien
comprendre qu'elle est problématique
jenny denizen dans quelques jours c'est
les vacances vous avez donc donner des
exercices ou aux élèves qui le
souhaitaient pour je leur ai pas donné
je leur ai conseillé jeudi aux parents
qu'effectivement
il fallait qu'ils poursuivent en fait
si c'était possible dans la mesure du
possible que je leur demande et au moins
un travail d'écriture c'est à dire
qu'ils écrivent ce qu'ils ont fait la
veille qu'ils racontent leur journée
type journal intime
voilà qui le destine ce que je me suis
rendu compte aussi qu'on demande
tellement aux enfants d'apprendre à lire
et à écrire tôt qu'on oublie de leur
apprendre à dessiner et que moi j'avais
des élèves qui quittent dessinée encore
des petits bonhommes comme en moyenne
section cette année c'est pour montrer
aussi que c'est également un moyen
d'expression et je leur ai surtout
conseiller la lecture donc que ce soit
des sous forme de journaux de bandes
dessinées tous les types de livre qu'on
a pu voir cette année et je leur ai
demandé effectivement de ne pas jeter
les travaux qu'on avait fait cette année
parce que c'était un jeu avec mes élèves
à chaque vacances qui le reprennent je
donne toujours la possibilité de
corriger une deuxième fois je corrige
vous faire mes exercices ensemble je le
corrige et ensuite je donne la deuxième
chance avec une couleur d'un autre
crayon pardon un crayon d'une autre
couleur je vais y arriver
et du coup j'arrive demandé de faire la
même chose avec leurs fiches de travail
pour les vacances d'été qui n'était pas
obligé d'acheter un cahier mais que
s'ils voulaient le faire par contre il
ya souvent des petits textes sur les
sciences sur des petites choses qui
peuvent être intéressants comme
exceptionnellement c'est ludique aussi
c'est l'uci sait qu'elle est ludique et
puis c'est surtout un moment de partage
puisque l'enfant n'y arrivera pas
forcément tout seul il a besoin de
l'adulte suivant l'âge qu'il a pour
pouvoir l'accompagner en tous les cas
dans la compréhension des consignes si
on demandait par par l'exercice
dans cette émission touche bientôt à sa
fin on va commencer à conclure je me
tourne vers vous et manuel afonso alors
est-ce qu'il faut mettre des cahiers de
vacances dans ses valises cet été
mètres des quais de vacances dans ses
valises si on en a envie
si on voit que lens on en a envie et
surtout et
à la limite si on n'a pas prévu beaucoup
de choses mais bon généralement on fait
confiance aux parents faire des
activités avec leurs enfants ça reste
une priorité pendant les vacances et je
pense que tous les moyens sont bons pour
pour les aider et puis on reverra le
cahier de vacances sur la fin sur la fin
du mois d'août pour se préparer
on attend de retrouver la maîtresse
notre michael tonnes il ya un rapport du
haut conseil à l'évaluation de l'école
de 2004 dont qui l'est c'est plutôt des
dates mais de ce que j'ai pu lire depuis
lire il ya des choses intéressantes
justement sur cette question mais qui
monte ça dépend vraiment des enfants et
la façon entre qu'on les utilise et et
au final je pense peut-être dire que ça
vaut aussi le coup peut-être de travail
est de faire en sorte que les enfants et
c'est une question de méthodologie en
fait la méthodologie après est
applicable partout plus que la question
de d'être sur des savoirs voilà et les
parents peuvent aussi s'investir dans
l'école à la rentrée
accompagnés ou devenir représentant
parents parce que est aussi mieux
comprendre le système éducatif parce que
c'est les études sont longues et
l'accompagnement que peuvent faire les
enfants les aussi et donc ils ont tout
intérêt à investir là peut-être même
plus que dans un cahier de vacances
soient vides onusienne pour conclure moi
je dirais que les vacances doit être un
moment de détente un moment de plaisir
et on partage donc donc j'encourage les
parents effectivement à faire des tas
d'activités avec leurs enfants et puis
d'inverser les rôles que l'enfant joue à
la maîtresse aux jo à l'adulte des fois
c'est très instructif aussi merci en
tout cas peu les trois d'être venu ce
soir voilà c'est la fin de ce sept huit
débats merci à tous de l'avoir suivi on
se retrouve mercredi prochain pour un
nouveau numéro
[Musique]